welcome to this video Jason believe on
Jason Bolivar let's see ya what kind of
yep the two nights and he's playing d3
mm-hmm okay going back to the Italian
game it is some very reliable and set up
for black this modern this modern line
against it it's called the modern
normally we should sorry night f1 can i
play Knight g4 here or is d for coming
or what is this totally totally moronic
to do that my play d4 ride okay I still
want to try okay it's not playing
deformed he's just trading stuff yeah if
i take here and I don't like that so
much what about this can I have no
official of some notion of seven is not
on but still maybe I can annoy him a
little bit with this pin I don't want to
take on e3 and give him the half-open F
file so I rather let him take and I
recapture with the rook
okay it's a typically solid Italian game
structure for white hurts it's sometimes
difficult for black to to break this
down get get some sort of imbalance but
let's see is taking quite some time yet
it does not look so problematic really
you cannot take on f7 if he does 95 I
take on GFI with the Queen and have a
piece up so I'm not quite sure what
exactly he's thinking about maybe about
if he wants to castle at all yeah I can
take but what I wanted to do is actually
really this which is maybe risky after G
for this Bishop it's a little bit out of
play but at least this and give some
imbalance this is what I would I want
you to try to win some sort of imbalance
ok so is h5 a move h5 he will go g5
yeah do I want to trade maybe maybe I
want to trade if he takes with the Queen
I'm I have some ideas at least to do
something on the Kings side here here
here thought h5 maybe age 5 g 5 h 44
bishop age 5 maybe I can try to UM play
against the g5 paw in a bit I will play
Queen e7 and long castling but maybe I
can play come in f2 Queen f2
now that's it's not great a play Bishop
h5 now you can take on on can take on
edge form okay now that's one of the
good idea h5 was mistyped and the edge
for the idea in itself is not that
terrible but the timing was really bad
okay he can maybe even just take on h4
let's get get out of the center yeah I
know take your own age voice some some
way for counter play
charu gauge fire fair this just does not
look any good but maybe I need to do
that night h4 g5 this kind of thing yeah
my knight on c6 now if you ever have
seen a stupid piece as this one maybe I
can play a 98 to e6 yeah okay week he
can take on h4 but at least at the end
he will have to deal with this week edge
pawn yeah I thought this one but maybe
not a five is good yeah yeah not much to
do if Knight a5 is good then okay so
beard okay yeah this is the very very
simple way to go about it which does not
mean that it's bad just as mentioned
simple and yeah probably here to go to
evade rook f8 Bishop e6 wasn't good so
trying to use the files
okay so some way doubling on the FR
maybe have a look here okay let's put
this back first it's not so easy for him
because yeah he's got them this at the
moment somewhat passive bishop and
Queenie six is also moved that is quite
interesting Queenie six it's a pen and a
tool maybe let's let's get this idea to
get let's get this done first queen is
six or Queen f7 they stay in the
position Jeff where to put this taking
it's not good g7 or is six maybe do some
are the same but we both don't look good
I would really would have liked to to
have a more active night but not much to
do now about it night see for the
possible idea okay look at seven Queen
f8 maybe using the F file now that's not
easy five minutes so easy especially is
really bad there is probably some way
for white but at the moment I think
along but I don't see it and this is not
at all easy
yeah I'm invading him this morning a big
issue who could detour can I do
something directly him with the with the
night maybe a five a4a three let's try
that look f3 on rook everyone maybe yeah
I want to keep it on the board a 4 is
still still interested in an issue in
three maybe d5 yes for a three check
made check yeah that was a naughty
little trick but it it was it wasn't so
it wasn't easy anymore it wasn't so easy
anymore I really miss played it
beforehand but i don't i don't know this
this operation here here should be ok
but let's go go go go about it step by
step this is a mistake definitely i
should i should just prepare long
castles like here and and and long and
this is probably about equal i mean i
can't play this and Bishop f7 for
example just do normal moves and it's a
normal yeah equal ish position probably
end here this is not good simply
especially can in connection with age
form yeah will almost certainly lose the
pawn now which also happened in the game
and I think if he is I think this helps
me a little bit at least in a practical
sense as now I'm getting some activity
and chat after this I'm definitely in
the game queen is 6 hi Queenie 6 was
interesting i only saw this idea later I
had this double a check maybe here
yeah I can take there is no discovery
can give give or Canada not on g5 but
you can give checks that they don't be
too much so this is what I should have
done but in a practical game I'm not in
such bad shape here because the the
extra power at the moment is not worth
that much and I have the F file so there
are there are chance to see em around
here it gets it gets it gets really
tricky here and d5 year I'm winning here
already I had this this feeling because
he cannot do this it's also made and
what exactly is he playing if he plays a
three for example I can take and I this
is shaky really shaky I had a computer
gives Queen a3 as a winner already which
surprises me that it's a win but ok e3
and e4 they both hang his king is
insecure and I'm attacking with all
pieces that I have left yeah it wasn't
it wasn't easy for him I'm worse but
it's still tricky alright thanks for
watching